brah OMG the energy in here is so
incredible look at its Garrett yeah I
got chills I'm sorry
since when do you care about football
bro are you kidding me football is like
my thing you found out the World Cup was
happening twenty minutes ago when you
texted me asking what I was doing to us
so much has happened since then bro
I am pumped let's go Brazil all of our
star players are back everybody if you
knew anything about football you'd know
that it's not about star players it's
about teamwork I understand how the
sport works back in high school I was
the sweeper and varsity captain just
because I didn't make varsity or junior
varsity or frost off how did you know
make frosh soft they basically let
anyone play right gonna sit here and
rehash high school politics we were you
the freshman lobster at tryouts who
tried to cast a level seven fireball on
Coach Morris and got laughed off the
field I'm the only other lobster who
went to our high school you know that
was Quinn how much damage would that
spelled of God wait no are we are we in
the death bracket Brazil's and crouppen
oh god I hope we're not in the bracket
of death
those goddamn judge I really regret
telling you I was here are you seriously
reading for Brazil yeah bro they're my
team they're all just like living
legends you got a Ronaldo you know you
got Ronaldinho I can't forget about
rahiba no Rana Donatello ah dude
Brazil's not even playing - FIFA World
Cup 2014
whoa lose your spot USA or what do you
mean boring I'm American like you we
root for USA okay but I called Julie I'm
100% Brazil person I've never been
outside the state possibility here's the
short wait is that it's a Fanta
commercial women what's a game back on
what what channel is this right now Shh
shut up shut up shut up
Dempsey's on they're interviewing
Dempsey oh my god yes yes I google how
to say beer in Portuguese his fitness
level is so incredible right now so
toned no one better to lead our squad to
victory this year oh hey Jared
she'll show you Kate what what are you
talking about I messaged you on Facebook
oh I'm just here with some of the girls
from work
are you still on Facebook at all so
you're into soccer now yeah I know it
was always your thing but I've really
gotten into it recently oh that's great
I hope you're not doing this for me just
show yourself funny that's crazy
excuse me posso tomorrow Huma sir Vega
there's a thirsty Brazil person here who
do you think Dempsey's best friend on
the team is
I really don't know what it's just so
much fun talking soccer with you shell
which one is Dempsey so why don't you
stay and enjoy a beer with us I should
really be getting back to the girls okay
you know what
sure great read the mini from me and
I'll tell you what beer I want of course
Jesus show don't order him around he's
not your boyfriend anymore okay just
like get over him you are a grown woman
you can read a menu by yourself thank
you
you're right Quinn I usually have other
people help me though because my
dyslexia is so bad oh you're dyslexic
Gary you should help her with that no
it's okay I'll do it myself I think I'll
just head back to my table one of the
girls will help me out with him in you
goodbye Garret queen bro that's super
sad he really should have helped her he
takes the shot oh wait it's the same fan
of commercial I keep keep missing
there's a giant bottle of Fanta playing
goalie and the person dribbling the ball
is also a giant bottle of Fanta yeah no
Brazil whoa again remember a few days
ago when you and I like pretended to
care about soccer no Quinn I'm I'm like
a really big soccer what an interesting
time in my life I'm really excited to
feel like Americans have finally
embraced football as like a spa
sup guys looking to sell in official
Brazil team Jersey size large also
looking to sell three full sized
Brazilian national flags just hit me up
the comments if you're interested